如果你想要修复跟孩子之间的关系的话，接纳这个词一定要每天在自己脑海里面过千万遍。就是接纳他之所以现在叛逆了，之所以现在对我感情没有那么好了，之所以现在不听话了，不乖了，学习成绩不好了，他是有原因的。我现在接纳他这个样子，只要他是平安的是健康的，我先接纳他是这么个情况，就是小孩子的事情，我应该从头到尾的说，还是说到目前的情况呢？没事儿，你从头到尾说吧。在小孩子出生之后呢，两岁多的时候，我跟他父亲感觉出现了问题，折折腾腾能折腾到4岁多的时候，然后就我就带着一个孩子，一个人就在外面租房子住，这样待了两年。这时候有个工作机会在外地，我就问孩子，我就选择权交给他，当时孩子6岁，我说是愿意我带还是愿意他爸带，他说愿意，他爸他说他爸给他买了玩具对他好。这个时候其实我有点伤心的，我想那也行，孩子需要条件好嘛，然后我就给他爸了。后面就在外面自己工作去了，孩子就给他爸了，给他爸还有后妈一起带，我就去工作。工作一年之后，然后这个时候我就办理了这个离婚手续。嘛之前一直没办，我当时孩子抚养全没要过来，他爸抢着要走了，因为他爸那边条件还是更好运。现在孩子是12岁哈入知到12岁之间，孩子一直都在他爸那。我就暑假寒假呀，国庆五一啊，我就经常去接。虽然他爸老不让我接，我就想尽个种办法去接，发现孩子问题挺。
多的不听话，再也没以前我在的时候那么乖那么听话了。然后学习也不好，性格也痞里痞气的。后来呢，慢慢的大了之后，小孩子表现能力越来越强了。就这两三年，每一次我就觉得他都会跟我讲，他说他的后妈对他不好，他爸爸对他也不是特别好，他爸就是对他比较简单粗暴，关注他的时间少，打他也打过，打的比较狠。他后妈是怎么那个后妈就是精神打压，一点小事挑刺儿，一点小事就骂他，而且在他爸面前一个样，他爸不在就是一个样。还有经常会跟他说，你妈不把你接走，我不带你，不要你不管你，让我带你，让你妈赶紧把你接走，就说这种话。在今年的时候，当时我就觉得我条件应该还行，应该适合这个能把孩子带过来，因为我现在目前在老家有一个小二手房，一个代步车工作的话就是有收入。目前，然后我就跟孩子说，我说，如果你要是实在过得很不开心，我说你就跟我在一起，我说我照顾你，只是可能比较艰苦，你要做好心理准备。他当时第一天他说他爸那个条件好些，他不愿意回来，我说，那也不勉强你，他考虑考虑第二天的时候，他就跟我讲说，他说他想明白了他愿意跟我，他就跟我在一起。暑假的时候，嫁到武汉嘛，我在武汉工作嘛，然后在9月1号回来了嘛，回到老家了，然后还是上他之前的学校。我在开学的时候待了一个星期，我陪着他在老家待了一个星期，但是我得上班呀，我不能一直带着他们，我就把家里各种吃的、喝的所有东西准备的很充足，前一共正好两个点。
厨房一个客厅一个，然后我就去上班去了。上班之后呢，老师昨天就给我发信息，他说孩子一直没做作业，开学到现在，然后我就很惊异，因为每次我问孩子都是他做的嘛，我就当即就赶回家了。昨天下午就赶回家了。我发现回到家里，我一看家里的很多吃的，我准备他不吃，他买了泡面堆在那，买了饮料堆在那，然后家里脏的跟个什么一样，就跟他流浪汉的时候没什么区别了。孩子回来之后，我也没有骂他，我只是很心疼嘛，我就心里记得的跟他讲，不是我不带你，但是这样现在这样的条件不太适合带你，还是得跟着你爸爸。因为毕竟在你爸那有吃有喝，有人陪伴你。他当时也就什么都没说，然后去做作业，他学习不是很好，他有很多数学上不是很会做，导致最后做到12点多，我学习也不好，不会辅导他这些，反正就最后做到12点多睡觉，然后到今天早上的时候呢，问题是什么？就是今天早上怎么叫他就是不起来，其实他已经醒了，但是他就是不起来，很对抗我，特别的对抗我，特别排斥我，特别对抗我，其实，这一两个月以来都没有过的我跟他好话说尽，歹话说尽，然后把他打了一顿，没用，就是不去。结果，我实在没有办法，我就跟老师请假了。他现在还在睡觉呢。然后现在遇到这样的问题，我觉得挺痛心的，可能是我确实是我做的不好，我高估自己不应该把他带过来，也可能是这个孩子已经问题很严重了，我不知道现在我该怎么做，我现在很矛盾，心里很难受。你今年是多大了？我今年39岁，还打算。
在成家吗？不打算，我一直都没离婚，都7年了，都是一个人单着的。我今天哦，听到那个武志红老师讲过一段话，我觉得挺触动我的。他说，其实我们的孩子不是因为优秀而被爱，是因为被爱才会优秀。你认真琢磨一下，孩子有的时候他是需要被我们接纳。像你的孩子某种程度上6岁跟着你，然后，6岁之后，跟着他爸又是一个后妈。那你有想过孩子在这6年的岁月当中，他受过哪些委屈，受过哪些打压？他有过哪些伤害？你穿着他的鞋，走过他的路，跟爸爸和后妈过6年，然后你再看看他今天的行为。他不管是叛逆也好，是对你排斥也好，某种程度上的话，他需要我们去接纳他这个过程，如果你想要修复跟孩子之间的关系的话，接纳这个词一定要每天在自己脑海里面过千万遍。就是接纳他之所以现在叛逆了，之所以现在对我感情没有那么好了，之所以现在不听话了，不乖了，学习成绩不好了，他是有原因的。我现在接纳他这个样子，只要他是平安的是健康的，我先接纳他。如果说他现在学习习惯不好，反正我也不想成家了，我也不想再生孩子了，我在这个世界上就这一个孩子，我哪怕说。
工作上，我少挣点钱，那个项目奖金，我少拿一点。可能用更多的时间去陪伴他，去接纳他人。只有在被完全的接纳过，被全方位的保护过，才有可能滋生出优秀的成长的心气儿。当然，这个我可能也站着说话不腰疼啊，因为你可能要面临生存问题。可能工作不是一时半会儿说我想少干点就能少干点，不是说出差我想不出马上就能不出的，但是如果我是你，我反正也不想改嫁，我反正也不想再生孩子了。我在这世界上就这么一个孩子，是吧？我得看看孰轻孰重，尤其是在他这个阶段，青少年这个阶段虚荣心很强，攀比心很强，又很敏感，各方面这个阶段的话，可能更多的是需要我去接纳他，仅供你参考啊，我觉得是这样，就是在暑假寒假我带着他的时候，他挺听话的。可能有时候就是我放假工作请假了嘛，给他好吃好喝，带着他好玩的他，他当然高兴。但是现在目前是因为我确实这个年的时间，我在他上学的这段时间，我没有照顾过他，我不知道他上学的这个状态是什么状态。但是今天我发现我经历这些事儿啊，还有平时的一些生活中的一些事儿的时候，发现有点管不住他，我有点管不了他了。因为孩子这么大了，你跟他说好话吧，他误不了，打他吧，他打皮了，因为他妈也经常打他，天不怕地不怕。
然后，这么大，你也不能强迫他怎么样。你把他抱着或者拉走也不行。我感觉有点管不了他了。我不知道你想问我的问题是什么啊。你想问我的问题，我猜测一下以下这么几个，第一个，该不该把他送回到他爸妈和后妈那里去？第二个，接下来你应该怎么办？你是不是大概想问我这么几个问题？对，如果你再一次把他送到他爸爸和后妈那里去的话，将来你可能要面临的就是孩子跟你确实不亲。以后如果你也不再婚了，那孩子以后不管是结婚啊，生孩子呀，孩子以后你老了呀，如果你能接受孩子跟你不亲的这个结果，那你今天可以这么选择。如果你害怕将来孩子跟你不亲，害怕面对那样的痛苦，那今天咱们就不要选择再把他送回去，因为你明明知道后妈对他不好，你明明知道爸爸不管他，你明明知道他现在一身的问题，你还把他送回去，相当于你再一次的抛弃了他。如果你觉得自己的能力不足以去纠正他的一些学习习惯，那么我们要求助专业的人，如果可以，请专业的老师来家里对他进行一些心理疏导，或者带他去专业的老师那里，专业的对孩子的一些行为呀，学习习惯呀，性格呀，心理呀各方面。
进行一些引导，那么我们就求助专业的人去找到专业的机构，而不是说当我发现我的这个孩子我管不住他了，我就放弃他。因为这孩子是我生的，除非说你告诉我这个孩子是什么超雄综合症，这孩子是什么天生坏种，这孩子干了什么缺德事儿，干了什么霸凌别人欺负别人的缺德事儿。如果咱对孩子没有到那一步的话，我就得挽救他，就得拯救他，是不是对的？但是怎么说呢，我现在一方面我心里是很纠结的，一方面我又担心把孩子送过去会让他造成再次的伤害，等于是好像再次抛弃他一样。我也担心我把他带到身边，有又外一边工作，一个人又是工作室带孩子，而且，这已经是一个出了很多问题的一个孩子了。我自己我不知道该怎么样才能把这个孩子教育好。我一方面有没有对自己，我有没有信心？你的这个工作是属于公务员吗？不是不是，但是我现在目前工资还比较稳定，就是比普通人要稍微高一点点吧。哦，那你现在手上有存款吗？有存款，我觉得人生就是取舍，就像我跟你掏心掏肺的讲啊，假设说当年我要是不去备孕，不去生这个小孩，不去带这个小孩儿，可能我能挣老多钱了。真的，因为那会儿流量又好啊，那会儿抖音各方面的生态环境都很好，我能挣老多老多钱了。但是人生它就是取舍，就是。
那现阶段这个生命对于我来说的话，我最想要的是什么？如果你现阶段你最想要的是这个孩子能够恢复到快乐的健康的心理，正常的能够跟你有亲子互动的这个关系的话，我们就要做取舍。人生有的时候，我们活这一辈子活的就是这么几个片段。可能当我取舍的时候，有一天，我发现我的孩子他可能不经意间说了一句，妈妈，谢谢你，妈妈，我觉得现在好幸福，可能你这辈子就活着一句话，就活着一个瞬间。其他的说，我们在事业上，我们多风光，有多少人夸我这个，夸我那个，可能他随着我年龄的增长，他都会被慢慢的淡化。就是有一天如果说孩子就说一句，妈妈，我觉得我自己好幸运啊，妈妈，我谢谢你就是在我脾气不好的时候，在我那个出问题的时候，你没有抛弃我。有的时候就活这么一个瞬间，这辈子就活这么一个瞬间。就是我现在的忧虑是什么呢？就很多人就讲说现在小孩子很自私，就是你现在对他再怎么好，你后来长大了，谁有钱跟谁亲，这是第一个顾虑，第二个顾虑，我怕我带着他到时候孩子孩子我又教育不好，然后最后钱钱没挣到一头都没落上。你自己权衡啊，自己权衡哪个阶段对于你来说什么事儿是更重要的。挣钱这个事儿啊，咱就是说一年之后你的能力会消失吗？
识字的能力会消失吗？你的视力会消失吗？你对社会的认知会消失吗？你认识的这些人都绝了吗？咱就说半年之后，一年之后，你挣钱的能力会不会消失？要重新开始了，那就挣钱能力确实会减弱很多，因为这就是一个黄金期限的，然后相当于会少挣很多很多钱，就得重新开始，会很难的。我也理解你啊，就这事儿的话，你再问几个人好不好？我的意见就只供你参考。那从我的个人的意见来说的话，第一，我也不准备再婚了，也不准备再生小孩儿了。第二，这个阶段可能是我的孩子问题最多的阶段，也是最关键的阶段，也是他最脆弱最需要我这个妈妈的阶段。第三，我有一定的存款，经济上也不是说吃不起饭了啊，第四，我也有一定的工作能力。第五，他的爸爸不管他，他的后妈对他不好，我可能不会选择把孩子再交回去，我可能会静下心来选择用半年的时间耐心的陪伴，请专业的人疏导，就是陪着他，接纳他，或者选择半年，或者想选择一年，我会做这个事情。这是我的个人的意见，仅供你参考，你也可以多问几个育儿专家，再问几个教育专家，问问他们的意见，然后你再做定夺，好不好？好就这样啊，很多姐妹也会有这个顾虑，我也理解大家就是说我把时间精力。
都投入到这个孩子身上，将来孩子不孝敬我，孩子觉得他爸经济条件好一点儿，又舔他爸去了。那我怎么看待这个问题啊？还是那句话，我客观的分析一下，我的孩子，他是属于天生坏种吗？他是属于那种恶魔型的小孩儿吗？他是属于超雄综合症吗？他是属于这一款吗？如果你要告诉我这个孩子是属于天生坏种，超雄综合症就是坏，就是根里，就是自私，就是坏透了。咱离开就离开了吧，咱不能给自己培养一个仇人，到时候来谋财害命，来杀了我，继承我的财产是吧？如果但凡这个孩子不是这样的天生坏种，他只是现在调皮，只是不听话，只是不懂事，只是有点心理问题，只是有点叛逆。那为了他，我可以不管是花半年也好，花一年也好，我就是接纳他，我就是陪伴他，我就是想用爱用爱再一次的接纳他，让他重新的去成长，重新的去生长。就小树哎，长歪了，就修一修，长直溜了他可能就会成为一个正常人，成为一个在社会上不会对别人造成伤害的这样一个人。至于说他以后说他想找他爸，从他爸那边搞点钱，我会觉得嗯，我儿子真厉害，我不会觉得我儿子背叛了我，偷偷找他爸要钱去了。我只会觉得我儿子真厉害，哎呀，管他爸骗他。
房太牛了，谁能懂我这个点？我不会觉得说他管他爸要钱跟他爸好就是背叛了我嘛。我不会这么想问题，我可能私底下我还得教他呢，还惦记你爸的财产呢，惦记你爸那套房呢，就这意思啊，记得点赞关注哦。